I'm the anchor desk on The Today Show
said Matt man can't do it forever we
need a little help at some point we hope
that you guys will join us a little bit
later this afternoon for more of our
innovation challenge we'll see you then
thanks very much stop who says that CBS
has got a quarter on the amazing race
we've got our own going on here on
education nation I'm joined now by Sal
Khan who in effect is one of the leading
innovators in the country but kind of
stumbled into it you are a computer
science enthusiast you got into the
venture capital business which you had a
nice across the country who was having
some difficulties doing her math what
happened then yeah it was 2004 they were
visiting me right after my wedding and
it just turned out that it came out
while we were just talking about it that
she she was getting tracked into a slore
math class when she was going into
seventh grade right after the summer and
I I doctor said nada you know you're
clearly a bright girl and we share a
certain amount of DNA there's no way
that you should be you know tracked into
a slower math class and so she agreed
that we would tutor each other or I
would tutor her when she went where was
she living and where were you living at
the time she was based in New Orleans
versus where I grew up but I was in
Boston at the time and so we agreed she
would go home and we would get on a
conference call we'd figure out
something and I use yahoo doodle to
tutor her and a couple of months later
that worked out then I start tutoring
her brothers couple of other cousins
whole time I still had a day job and
about about a year later it just became
hard for me to scale myself I had
trouble scheduling with all my different
cousins and family friends and all the
rest and I had a buddy who I was talking
to over dinner and I said you know I'm
really enjoying this tutoring thing that
I do after after work but it's getting
difficult and he's like well why don't
you just record your lectures and put
them on YouTube and and and I said no
YouTube's for dogs on skateboards it's
not for serious mathematics but I tried
it out and and you know long story short
my cousin said that they liked me better
on YouTube than in person
the and other people they do and they
just kept watching and so now it's about
two two and a half million people a
month or watching the videos and you've
got about 2,200 videos it's now pushing
2,800 videos on everything from basic
addition to vector calculus and biology
and chemistry and whatever else it's
just a commercial enterprise are you
doing this just to keep the country
better in point no and then you know it
a lot of my buddies from the very
for-profit investment world are
wondering what happened to sell but I
decided to make it a not-for-profit and
the real idea is is that you know the
fun of this is that it reaches as many
students as possible so you know what
I'm on my deathbed I want it would be
nice you know you for-profit realm a big
success would have been the IPO or you
get acquired but here the big success is
it can reach millions and millions of
kids so it's pretty exciting what's the
appetite for learning that you're
finding from this generation especially
in the difficult sciences like math
because we know we're behind in this
game you know the really surprising
thing is my cousins were fairly
motivated students they were having
trouble but I was I was helping them and
when i made the videos i assume that
they would be that the the appeal would
be for people like my cousin or maybe
people like myself i was a pretty good
student when i was in middle school and
all the rest but the really big surprise
the letters I get her from students who
a lot of us would have traditionally
labeled as the disengaged students the
students who who said i was about to
fail out of algebra i was about to drop
out of high school until I found this
type of a resource and the big message
to me is is that it's actually a much
larger group of students who really
really really learn and you just have to
give them an outlet so they're not
frustrated so they're not they don't
feel like they're being talked down to
and if you give them that it's not just
the five or ten percent of students want
to learn it's the ninety ninety-five
percent so we were proceeding panels as
you know we talked a lot about poverty
socio economic deprivation people not
having access to the inner
so are you talking effectively to those
who are privileged or in the if not
elite class and certainly in the middle
to upper-middle class you know we're
across the board I mean we've we've seen
clearly I think the main barrier here is
that there is some type of Internet
connectivity that someone needs to do
but people are already ticking our
videos they're being translated into 11
languages and putting them on dvds I've
gotten pictures of people using them in
rural Africa and rural India so even now
it can be accessed by people anywhere
and then as we go forward the cost of
technology is just getting cheaper and
cheaper and I think you know I think
there's some healthy skepticism around
technology in the classroom or
technology for learning and I think the
reason why South is because there was
nothing to do with the technology and
and we're hoping that between our videos
and then we have a huge software
platform that's what to give exercises
and feedback to students that that will
be a catalyst to really to use
technology what's the difference between
teaching online and teaching in the
classroom the classroom management's a
little bit easier no but I said it
jokingly but it's true i mean i get a
huge luxury that when i would i make my
videos i pretend that the students are
so enthralled by what i have to say that
i can just you know imagine it and but
what's good about that is it gives me
energy I mean I guess much harder to sit
in front of a room full of 30 kids and
you're not sure whether some are getting
it somewhere there some are here and
when it happens is that I that energy
can gets conveyed in the videos and when
the students watch it they can pause and
repeat as many times as they want I just
got a letter from a kid who watched one
video 30 times and it took him 30 times
to get the idea and what he said is that
there was no one on the planet he could
have paid to watch a video to tutor him
that concept 30 times without judging it
and I think that's what students really
like you do have a non-profit you're out
there in the universe of cyberspace but
are any of the educational systems in
this country the district's heathyr at
the local or state level coming to you
and say how can we strengthen the
relationships between what we need and
what you
yes so we started some pilots last year
just almost on a whim and they've it's
gotten pretty exciting some of the local
schools and in the the Bay Area they
said what would you do if you could do
anything with a fifth grade classroom we
said we'd have every student working at
their own pace watching videos doing the
self-paced exercise is only moving
forward once they've mastered concepts
right now you get a B or C on a topic
that's fine you pass even though you
don't know ten or twenty percent of the
material and then you move on to more
difficult topic so we're saying everyone
at their own pace Master concepts first
and then what happens to the teachers
that they get all of this data who's
working on what what videos are they
watching what exercises are doing and so
the teacher no longer has to give these
one-size-fits-all lectures the teacher
can actually get the data and say hey
look Tom's having trouble of negative
numbers everyone else is working at
their own pace let me sit down next to
Tom and actually have a one-on-one
intervention with Tom so what we found
in these classrooms has been pretty
crazy is that before maybe ten percent
of a teacher's time was spent on that
really deep one-on-one mentorship now
it's ninety percent of their time so so
the what we consider to be the relevant
metric which is student to time with the
teacher ratio that's gone through the
roof and people in their 40s and 50s or
my age and I'm a grandparent of this age
do we tend to underestimate the passions
and the almost affinity that young
people now coming of age with all this
technology around them have for using
that technology and the expectation that
they have yeah yeah no I mean it it
surprised me I wouldn't have thought
when I started this off I wouldn't have
thought when I made videos on on sine
cosine or lapa Tom's rule that they
would become this mainstream thing but
clearly there's this there's this hunger
for it and any with a surprising thing
it isn't just a younger generation we
have 30 year olds 40 year olds 50 year
olds I got a letter from a grandmother
who said it was her life dream to learn
calculus who knew and she started
working on it so it's really across
generations do you compliment
to do online with conventional textbooks
or math books or offer references well
you know it's it's a it's an interesting
I think they'll always be a role for
books but what textbooks right now due
to things they the text tries to teach
you something it's sometimes hard to
read and then and then the exercise try
to give you practice and we think that
on-demand video is often better than the
text that you see in a lot of textbooks
and that kind of immediate feedback
self-paced learning with data and
analytics and you get the steps of every
problem and it's kind of like a video
game that that's better than you know
every other answer in the back of the
book so so it'll be interesting to see
what happens to the textbook world what
have you learned if anything at this
point and I know its empirical evidence
probably about whether some of us are
hard-wired to do math and others of us
like me are hardwired to do other things
I mean people ask me how I got to be a
journalist I say algebra 2 that's pretty
good no the the amazing thing that we
started seeing these pilots in these
classrooms is when you let every kid
work in their own pace right when you
start off you do see what we
traditionally see some of the kids race
ahead and those are the kids that we all
think are going to be nuclear physicists
and whatever else and some of the kids
take a take a little bit longer on one
concept to another in a traditional
model you would say okay those kids are
meant to be scientists and engineers
these kids maybe they'll become maybe
they'll become journalists orissa which
isn't so bad but but the the what we've
seen is is if you let them work at their
own pace some of those kids who are
spending a little extra time on negative
numbers or exponents you give them that
extra time as soon as they get that some
of them just race ahead and so what
we're seeing in our data in the
classrooms is when we're not grouping
kids based on early assessment that
every week there's a new leader and some
of the kids that 23 weeks ago you would
have said we're slow or below average a
week or two or a month later they're the
best kid in the class and so what we're
seeing is is that maybe we're just
discounting kids too early and that
we're assessing them at the wrong times
and we're just kind of it's kind of a
predetermined future if you do it that
way how do we lose our way in this
country when it came to science
education
well how did we lose our away when it
comes to science education in this
country you know it's a younger guy I
mean the Russians were being us into
space for a lot of people went in
engineering went into sciences the space
race hope they accelerate all that but
then we lost our way it seems to be in
the last part of the 20th century you
know I think it's just been bad Brandi I
think you know it's funny because
science and engineering or fundamentally
creative professions I mean engineering
the word engineering is to build things
that have never been built before and
the way it's it's shown and the way in
all of the hoops that you have to jump
through through your education make it
look like it's a non creative field but
when you actually get in the real world
it is a very creative field so i think i
think the real thing to get more kids
engaged is to show them that one just
the math and the science itself is
beautiful and it tells us more about the
universe or as much about the universe's
philosophy or anything else it really is
a form of philosophy and not only that
but the end point you're going to isn't
a boring job it is a creative job it is
redefining what people's experiences are
and I think if you view it that way I
think there'll be a lot more people want
to get into it I think of cyberspace is
the new second big bang we're creating
this new universe out there just like we
did with yep physical first bank one of
the things that's happening is that
we're watching all these planets which
one's going to drip too close to the Sun
which ones are going to form together in
four new life forms as you look at your
model which has been successful have you
already begun to think how can we expand
that model to other areas yeah we've
already thought about it so you know we
have the videos i do right now and then
we have this whole software platform and
i think the interesting thing is we're
going to start branching off from
mathematics into our videos already
cover other things in biology and
economics and all the rest but our
exercise platform start do economics
physics chemistry and then start to
think about how can we do the humanities
how can we give people basic scaffold of
say American history and then I think
it'll be really interesting to see how
we can do things like creative writing
where people are doing projects and
maybe they can peer review each other's
essays and things like that and so I
think there's a whole universe that
we're just beginning to explore look
forward
coercion so thank you very much from the
Khan Academy thank you and you now get
together later and see if we can prove
my mouth